exciting the salaries paid to some chief
executives and footballers utterly
ridiculous Jeremy Corbyn this morning
called for a wage cap to be imposed on
the country's biggest wage earners but
by this afternoon he appear to have rode
back considerably after his former
advisor the one-time Bank of England
monetary policy committee member Danny
Blanchflower branded the idea totally
unworkable here first of all is what the
Labour leader told sarah-jane me this
morning the first three days of this
year many top executives have already
earned as much as the rest are going to
earn in a whole year this has to be
addressed what would be the cap then
because you could argue that if you cut
off all those top earners all those fat
cats those top executives they pay the
top level of income tax so you'll be
missing quite a bit of money from them
how would you make up that up well they
would be obviously having a slightly
less of their enormous pay levels which
would then be available for investment
and development of their companies or
indeed our society as a company wouldn't
go it wouldn't go to benefit the
taxpayer
well actually an economic development
does benefit the taxpayer because more
people work and more people get jobs as
a result of that and therefore pay taxes
and so we'd have an expanding economy
but later in mr corbyn's big policy
speech this afternoon came this you
could set a limit on top pay I think
it's probably better to look at the
ratio issue because that indeed would
then encourage wage rises lower down and
ensure a better sharing of the resources
and the profits of any company so if mr.
Corbyn does take the idea further does
it make economic sense Ben Wilmot is the
head of public policy at the CIPD the
professional body for human resources
and in our central London studio is
Steve Davis from the Institute of
Economic Affairs well then let me start
with you it sounds as though mr corbyn's
already rode back on this I mean nowhere
else in the world really has this
support from Cuba and Egypt do they know
I think he's you know he's basically
raising attention on this this sort of
growing disconnect between you know top
pay and an average pay and certainly
CIPD research
shows that 7 and 10 employees believe
chief executive pays is too high and six
interns say the level of protective pay
is a demotivating factor in the
workplace so I think you know there is
definitely real need to look at pay and
and and whether chief execs are being
paid proportionately to the contribution
of the wider workforce and particularly
in relation to the performance of the
organization okay Steve I mean clearly
we've heard from Ben here the idea is
unworkable that's what most top
economists is saying this idea of a wage
cap but do you accept Ben's point that
something needs to be done there is
clearly dis consent about top pay isn't
there well there may be discontent but
it's not clear that there's really a
problem in what is driving top pay not
just in commerce but as you write you
say in sport and law and quite number of
other areas is the fact that
increasingly we live in a globalized
world and so law firms football teams
companies are in a global market for
talent and given that we're competing
with China North America other parts the
world this is inevitably going to drive
up pay at the very top now even if you
do think there's a problem though it's
not at all clear to me to put it mildly
that this is any business of the
government the people who should be
concerned about it if it is a problem
are the shareholders in the companies in
question and they're the people who
should be acting at this problem where
there's no role for the government in
this area in my view do you think your
shareholders are doing enough um well
quite frankly no at the moment we know
we're not seeing shoulders using their
ability to have a binding vote on on pay
I think there's a case to look at you
know how frequently shareholders can
have a nap a binding vote on pay but I
do think that it Keith Inge is is about
performance and if you look at the
performance of or corporations footsie
hundred corporations relative to the
rewards of chief executives over the
last two decades the rewards of chief
execs far outstrip performance and at a
time we've got a productivity problem in
the UK you know certainly that is part
of the mix so and I think the other
thing isn't in terms of you know talent
the war for talent very interesting
research by the LSE
fear based on interviews with large
executive search companies responsible
for pointing about 70% of footsie
hundred chief executives over the last
few years that was searched found that
headhunters themselves say that the
highest the level of high pay is
absurdly high and they also said that
for every chief executive they appoint
they could find a hundred equally
capable candidates so of course you know
we need talented hard-working chief
executives but they are not another
species but sorry Steve that would kind
of give them right to your point about
it being a global market for talent
wouldn't it if there are plenty of other
people available to do some of these
jobs well there are always plenty of
people available to do jobs of a
particular salary the question is
whether or not they're as good as the
people you actually appoint in the end
now the argument that's being made here
is that essentially there's no
difference between the people you pick
and the next 19 or 20 on the list
sometimes that is obviously is true but
the thing is there is a relatively small
number of people who really do make a
difference and that's true whether
you're talking about senior management
or top football players or top lawyers
now the thing is you really want to try
and get hold of those people very often
you're going to narrowly miss out from
them or you'll appoint somebody who you
think on the basis of their CV is in
that category but they're not but it's
the rewards that those small number of
exceptional people get that tends to
drive the market for everybody else
that's the nature of a market in top
talent I'm afraid now it obviously there
are problems in terms of as was
mentioned by Benna the demotivating
effect this may have on people lower
down the salary scale but I think that
that is something that shareholders need
to perhaps take into account and also I
would say there is a tendency for
companies to use the pay of their senior
managers as a kind of signal that
they're not an average company by paying
above the average and of course that's
mathematically impossible there have to
be some companies to paying the average
salary so there is a certain element of
an arms race here but I think that's
overstated I think it is rather the
competition for that small number of
what you might call superstars or to
identify superstars as driving this